بعد ما كانوا وخير سفراء لبلادهم يعود
ابناء وليد الرجراجي الى ارض الوطن لتكون
في استقبالهم حشود غفيره وصل عددها لعشرات
الالاف واتت من كل حدب وصوب في شوارع
الرباط اصطفى المغاربه لالقاء التحيه على
اعضاء منتخب الوطني الذي سطر اسم المغرب
باحرف من ذهب في تاريخ كره القدم العالميه
خلال بطوله كاس العالم التي نظمتها قطر
فاجا المنتخب المغربي والعالم اجمع اطاح
بمنتخبات المصنفه الافضل عالميا كبلجيكا
وكندا واسبانيا والبرتغال واضعا حدا لاخر
فرصه لكريستيانو رونالدو للفوز بكاس
العالم
اسود الاطلس كانوا اول منتخب افريقيا
وعربي يصل الى الدوري نصف نهائي قبل ان
يخسروا امام فرنسا حمله اللقب في 2018
وكرواتيا صاحبه المركز الثاني انا ذاك
فسرقوا قلوب عشاق كره القدم في العالم
اجمع ليس فقط بادائهم في الملعب ولكن ايضا
بالسلوكهم مع امهاتهم في مدرجات الملاعب
بعد انتهاء كل مباراه
فكان لرضا الوالدين ما كان في القصر
الملكي
العاهل المغربي محمد السادس استقبل
اللاعبين وامهاتهم وقلدهم اوسم ملكيه
مول الحسن حكيمي ومرابط وبونو وزياش
ورفاقهم جعلوا الجماهير المغربيه تطمح الى
المزيد من الانجازات في المونديال المقبل